LeBron scoots in Lebron over Jefferson
fre three nice reverse for
LeBron James on the drive James on the
answer Miami on a 12 to3 run make it 15
to
three k three three threes tonight
wow
LeBron out the tip in so James has 21
LeBron looking kid gilis right in the
eyes and then knocking it home no
stopping King James LeBron against kid
gilchris
kaboo now LeBron James four of four from
three-point L Kaboom LeBron James Why
Stop Now already the 23rd game this
season where LeBron has reached at least
30 points step back and
deliver eight points in a row for King
James the eater up 12 LeBron for three
Kaboom they season High six triples for
James chers missing James the exact
opposite he's been near perfect tonight
bron James on center stage tonight for
the heat drives in and scores
again 12 points on the quarter for
LeBron he also drew the foul LeBron
James with 39 points oh man can it look
any easier for LeBron
James another three for James he's seven
of
seven so LeBron James seven of seven can
he do it again yes eight for eight from
Kaboom Town 49 points for LeBron King
James welcome to his kingdom three on
the shot clock LeBron driving in he's
got 51 that ties his heat alltime
scoring high as a Heat
player he did it there it is another
jumper for James 53 for lebrown two more
for James he has 55 he's tied Twain Wade
for the second highest scoring game in
heat history he's one point away from
tying Glen Rice's franchise record James
off the spin for the record LeBron James
has a Miami Heat record 57 points in
tonight's game Glen Rice your record
last year for 19 years and now is number
two it's
good 59 for LeBron
James the first 60o game in Miami Heat
history you know LeBron very rarely is
satisfied I think right now with a top
coming off he's he knows he's done
enough he's getting the love from the
the heat Nation right now inside the
American Airlines Arena 26 years of Heat
basketball tonight the highest scoring
game in franchise history LeBron's 61
Majestic B in his jaw Irving with Felton
right in his face difficult
shot Irving steps up that's a
three-pointer in and out and in again
that's two times for the
Cavaliers Irving shot again is good
Irving nearly deflected by Chandler
here's the double team nearly deflected
by Pion Irving back door nice pass on
the Bounce from
verou all the players have talked about
that Irving puts up a three and Nails it
it's a two-pointer his foot was on the
line this kid is good because he can
shoot Mike and he has the rest of the
game as well penetrating creating be out
to the basket Banks it in and it's back
to four
again
both teams coming up with big defensive
deflections Irving down the
lane and it's a two-point game with 55
seconds remaining see how Irving never
in a hurry quick but always under
control and the last three Hoops have
come in the paint for the Cavaliers 33
for Irving crowd on its
feet Irving gets it deep in the corner
fires up a three and puts it in Irving
Miss the three-pointer and it's back to
six Kyrie Irving with a career high 36
points 12 of them here in the fourth
[Music]
[Applause]
quarter Irving again another
three-pointer from Kyrie
Irving the masked man putting on a
show I think everyone knows who he is
now he's enjoying the bright lights of
Madison Square Garden his in at the end
of the Portland game on Friday night he
says you know it happens so quick it's
kind of scary to feel your face and
understand that it's deformed and he
takes a crack in the face mask Thunder
tickets Grant splits the difference on
his free throws Westbrook elevates at
the top of the K and score I think not
bam offline Ibaka with the
recovery setting Westbrook one is giddy
up and he rides it all the way to the
state takes his lead at 32- 17 Westbrook
racing Westbrook
elevating the two-handed sledgehammer to
stop the bleeding Henry Sims able to
step out and knock it down Sims the
seconde pro at of Georgetown Westbrook
at the three-point line thunder on the
high side Thompson denied inside Mitch
McGary blew him up Thunder's got a
chance to add to the lead McGary from
Westbrook count the basket
and listen to this crowd a chance of B
Arena he won't
fall for
Samson Westbrook going to pull up in
front of jakar Samson Thunder defense
able to catch up and it's steal by
Westbrook on the run out Russell waits
for Noel to go flying by and Westbrook
has 20 from
downtown he is lighting it
up West keep and that lead is 15
again Westbrook off the screen from aaka
schores he just can't leave third quar
ker with the rebound Philadelphia has
outscored the Thunder 13-2 the last
three minutes Westbrook in the
[Applause]
[Music]
game McGary set up by Westbrook that's a
reward here big fella you worked it
Westbrook setting up carison on the
screen and roll Russell will attack
he'll get it back he'll reverse his
score who is that mass man that was
amazing to have the presence of mind to
get his own
rebound and what a turn by number zero
gets good help from Ibaka who comes and
gets another
block Serge has
four Westbrook scores and
run
in a nice little rhythm here with a
five-point lead Westbrook pulls up fires
and scores over Noel have come to light
off of the three free throws by Jason
Richardson Westbrook off the screen from
kis and
scores now you got to get stop secures
the
victory but you got to play it but I saw
one mask rendering in Facebook the end
of the Utah game that's that's a
makeable shot for has that's a makeable
shot for Toby Bryant who has despite the
mask J better shots into fast break
point BR knocks down a
jumper Kobe Bryant difficult shot makes
it look
easy Bryant little shake and bait draws
the foul put it in and
one Kobe Bryant an authoritative start
he's four for four from the field well
he's been living in the low post and one
thing you always have to do as he goes
into his Elijah on Shake is to stay down
on all of those fakes rightful pass to
goo two onone to Kobe
Bryant and Bryant knocks it in five for
five for
Bryant Bryant left open knocks that one
down he's seven for nine plastic put it
over top of that and made the mask cut
out the eyes obviously it's not
affecting him today but he has
complained about it being too Bryant now
on LeBron
[Applause]
James left handed shot way off defense
from Kobe Bryant 20 points at the half I
mean do it in in all different ways
there you see him driving to the basket
here you going to see a step back
beautiful one leg and then you said it
JB you said he's getting that move from
Dirk that one leg Yeah the raised leg
Fade Away jump shot but look we talked
about the broken nose that was obviously
a big talk was there going to be just
running better his legs are underneath
him oh tough shot for
Brian Bader single coverage now chers
looks to help how you defend that he was
the Heat play defensively surprised it
hasn't happened more briyan shot that's
[Applause]
good with about a second to spare on the
8 second violation Bryant knocks it
down big bucket from kobby Bryant he's
got 28
five to five to go with a shot clock
Bryan pulls up drills it kobby Brian
again and it's a 10-point game with two
and a half to play Jeff and and this is
what you need against a great defensive
team Bryant on the right hand dribble
pull up that is just beautiful to
watch Lakers but he couldn't hold on to
it Bryan gets it puts it up and puts it
in he it number of big shots and James
is hurt great find by
Gasol very All-Star game like that was
that was speaking of allstar game right
is two more for Kyrie Kyrie in such good
control when he's going full speed to
the basket both got to the lead you and
he were good friends till you skipped
his wedding oh he is so
mad Kyrie knocks it down and will'll get
to the
line Kyrie a deep three
wow what what a read by isolation
against a guy who's going to be bigger
like Al
Horford b gets picked off and Kyrie
drills the jump
shot forget about the best back court in
the East 4847 final minute here opening
half
Irving eight for eight now in the game
incredible track down by Horford
[Applause]
Kyrie pull up three oh my
goodness Kyrie Tatum running the floor
makes the catch and the save smart with
the hustle
play saves it
again Kyrie for
three Kyrie with the Miss Irving the
other way keeps going with the dribble
keeps it alive spins back Banks it
home
Kyrie off the dribble through a crowd to
the basket once again pushing that ball
through two Defenders getting themselves
right to the
rim Kyrie will stop a go move again tie
game at 100 Kyrie with
[Applause]
41 Irving again pull up jumper Nails
it Kyrie spins takes it into paint
backing his way down off the finger
roll Kyrie Irving showing why it's his
world look at the back down taking his
time spins there goes Matthews doesn't
matter
[Music]
right wow wow was right this a superhero
versus m
Mortal five in the shot
clock Brown takes
makes brown comes away with
it accelerates
two yeah Mike wanted a big KNE from
Jaylen Brown he's been
delivering oh I
see what's your like analysis of the
Celtics as we head into the playoffs
when we're healthy everybody we're
locking ready ready to roll
yeahoo and and we have another obviously
we have Jason Tatum who does the same
thing both very we're a very physical
offensive
[Applause]
team
oh
wow Jaylen Brown off the Celtics pushing
it throwing it down he got like under oh
my gosh is
gracious man he was fouled yeah that was
an and one all right fine you're going
to take a contested two and we're going
to go over here and move the ball yeah
the worst thing you could do is try to
go at match and no one would no one ever
wanted to settle on me I know there's
the three killer defensively offensively
for us to win every game but to win it
all yes I feel like everybody has to be
that way
[Music]
swe
Brown
wow all right Jaylen Brown on the
Baseline he's bigger he's stronger he's
playing with better Pace I think he's
improved since going to the allstar
game here's a spin easy too so we got a
guy chasing him down doesn't really
matter this his next level He's just
never knocked off his
line waste any time
[Music]
here oh nice move oh my
goodness here we
go there it is there it is sub them out